when I was speaking to this professor of
religion named Diana Pula she was saying
Kurt don't worry that the half of the
world thinks that I am God and so on
because you don't know what they mean by
that I don't have the like I have an
idea of what they mean could be
misinterpreting what they mean they
could be wrong at the same time millions
and billions of people have been wrong
all of these practices meditation and
psychedelics they're meant to be done
with the community and all these
insights she said she would imagine if
you went to some leader and you told
them this Insight they'd be like oh no
no no that's what that that's completely
wrong like you're not you are not God
like you are an aspect of God or
whatever it may
be and then she also said the Plato's
Cave journey is what's what's happening
or the dark KN of the Soul she used that
phrase she said the actual full story of
that or you think this is reality the
wall you come out you feel like that's
an illusion then the end of the story is
to somehow realize that what you thought
was real in the beginning is indeed real
it's just real in another manner like
somehow Mor real and then I remember
something Bernardo that you said look at
this this we think of as solid we feel
it there's solidity to it yet we look at
it through a microscope and we say yeah
the atoms are far apart this this
solidity is an
illusion that's if you take materialism
as primary what if you take your
conscious experience no no this is solid
this actually is solid there's something
real about that there's something real
about this table there's something real
about me inhabiting this world I can go
through this process where I feel like
oh that's all an illusion but then
there's this quote about TS Elliot that
the point of the journey is to come back
where you started and know the place for
the first time I feel like that I'm
slowly starting where I feel the reality
of this more I feel it but then there's
a negging part of me that's like yeah
you're tricking yourself G you're
tricking
yourself we let our theories hijack the
reality of our experiences and that's a
tragedy experiences are not nothing
they're the only thing that is really
real that's not just abstraction so it
doesn't matter that you oh there are
atoms here and then the distance between
the electron orbitals and the nucleus is
enormous relative to the to the diameter
of the particles themselves yeah it's
all true but you experience this you
hold this it has weight it has texture
it feels moist and it satiates my thirst
this is all real stuff now a conceptual
understanding a conceptual narrative
behind that may be true or not but it
doesn't take away from the experience
whatever this is it is an experience and
it is real as such the problem is that
we we we are in a society which in
implicitly tells us experiences in
themselves are nothing it's the thing
that lies behind the experience that
counts that that's absolutely
nonsensical all we have is experience
the narrative behind it can help us
develop a certain understanding but not
by robbing us of the immediacy of
experience which ultimately is is all we
have we can add understanding to that
but that understanding is a layer on top
of the immediacy of experience and look
the ego exists it's a tool without it I
wouldn't know to which mouth to bring
the fork so there is something there
that we call the
ego now is it your subjectivity in and
of itself or not that's a valid question
I would answer that it the ego is not
your subjectivity it it's it's a certain
configuration of experiences or a
narrative within your subjectivity and
yes idealism ultimately is a form of
cosmic solipsism and you can dip your
toes in those Waters and you recoil from
it I call it the vertigo of Eternity
um it's a place that um is very hard to
visit very hard to confront um which may
be a clue to why we are here you know in
this form um but maturing has always to
do with poking you out of your comfort
zone and and and and buffeting you a
little uh and and you just have to hold
the boat together so we can continue to
navigate and not sink but I I don't
think there is anything intrinsically
bad about the fact that the waters are
trying it's it's trying stuff uh and
that's how we progress and I I'm not a
prophet I'm not going to predict your
future and you come from a different
place than than me your life has a
different context what holds to me may
not hold to you doesn't hold to you
but now I'm going to do exactly what I
said I wouldn't do which is make a
prediction sure so forgive me for that
okay but there will moment there will
come a moment when you realize that your
problems will dissipate not because you
answered your questions but because you
no longer feel the need to ask
them yeah I'll leave it at that okay so
Chris whatever thoughts come to you and
then we can move on to another couple
questions I'm sorry to go on this aside
you were just communicating with your
own highest level of identity that's so
okay that's that's basically God and the
reason you are able to communicate with
God is that you are an aspect of God
right God is reality he's the Ultimate
Reality he almost has to be that way
otherwise it makes no sense to gow
something to God okay you are a part of
God and you are a stratom of God's
identity simple that and you give rise
to things and your
experiences they are identities your
experiences experience is not something
that can it is it's one unary you know
coherent thing and yet it can be teased
to parted into this idea of form and
substance okay it's basically an
experience is an interface it's an
interface between you and reality it's
you accepting input from the outside
world or internal input from yourself
okay and transducing it and then turning
that into a thought or into Behavior
okay this is this is what it is this is
what it's doing for you so your
experiences even your your purely mental
experiences are of utmost value to you
they are identities that are that are a
part of your identity and you are a part
of a greater identity okay so you've got
this Continuum of identities all right
and it's it's a nested it's it's kind of
a you know it's a it's Russian doll so
it's it's you
know Matuska you Matuska dolls I forget
anyway basically it's one thing nested
within another you've got a highest
level of identity your identity is
nested in it and your experiences are
nested in you they're all identities
okay putting all of those things
together is what it seems to me that
you're doing a very very valuable thing
so I'm saying keep up the good
work well hey man like any compliment
from you is it's an honor so let's just
end this with what you all value what do
you value most
most Chris what do I value most uh
God what's the identity of reality um
and of
course supporting and and aiding the
Fulfillment of reality I believe that
reality actually has a goal a
teleological purpose that it that it is
that it is determined by its structure
basically it's built into what it is and
that it is my job to fulfill help
reality fulfill that that that its goals
its teleological impetus which derives
from its structure because I'm a part of
it and it's my own highest level of
identity and it's my job to help it just
as as it helps me okay I'm carried
within it I exist within it so I'm going
to return the favor and I'm going to try
to reinforce it as much as I can that's
what's valuable to me and then of course
we have all of the things that are
valuable to everybody you know the idea
of of love you know I mean I have a wife
I have home I have you know pets I have
dogs that uh that love me you know the
taste of a good meal you know or a good
drink right having fun with your friends
right going out and enjoying nature all
of those things are valuable to me but
the one the one basic imperative that I
feel is to integrate with reality
perfectly help reality reinforce itself
right because that's all there is there
is nothing outside of that you try to
extricate yourself from reality like
like the the Buddhists are trying to do
and you end up in Nirvana and you're
nothing your identity has at that point
fused without a the entire universe and
you no longer have an individual
identity at all your identity is a
self-distributed thing that covers
everything and you have lost your
identity as you know okay you're here
and you feel your individual identity
and that's very very important okay your
job your job the the job of your
identity is not only to enjoy life as
you were put here to do but also to help
life and to help reality reinforce
itself right that's what I consider
B
Bernardo uh the answer I will give you
is not the answer I would like to give
you I would like to tell you I value
love the
most relationships the most human
decency and
Justice
um n is struggled with this question
and he answered power power is what cons
he considered the most important the
will to power in contrast to Freud's
will to
pleasure um but the truth is and you
know part of maturing is accepting your
own truths and know the truths about
yourself even when you don't like it the
truth is that for me the most important
thing is
truth and that um out
probably surrender everything else to
stare the truth in the face whatever the
price whatever the cost that for me is
is is the highest calling it's how I'm
put together it's not how I wish I was
put together
um to to prioritize truth above all else
is not trivial yeah again n he was very
explicit about that he said why do we
want to know the truth truth what's the
point he he thought it was ridiculous it
was a knee-jerk
reflex that if we thought it through we
would abandon it's not about what is
true um and I I've meditated on that for
years I I went to the extreme of
visiting the places where n had those
thoughts which thank goodness are
recorded we know where he was and I
probably stood within a meter of where
he
stood um but at at the end of all that
struggle it's it's the truth that shines
through and the truth is my highest
commitment is the truth that that's how
I am I I yeah I hate it in a sense but
that's how I
am thank you all so much for coming out
this was thank you thank you all this
was well enlightening in many ways okay
I would just once again repeat after
that after that that inspiring comment
by bernado that truth and reality are
basically two ways of looking at the
same thing when you say that's real or
something is real you are saying that it
is true okay and when you say that
something is true you're saying that
it's real so in dedicating yourself to
truth you also dedicate yourself to
reality and both of our combats both
what what what both of us said combined
in this one truth this one real
truth the same thing if you enjoyed that
clip then the full podcast is out right
now you can click around here enjoy
subscribe to theories of everything to
get notified of upcoming podcasts as
there are new fulllength podcasts every
week on the topics of mathematics
physics Consciousness Free Will and
AI